[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel
invité de la rédaction aujourd'hui nous
avons posé nos caméras au sein de
l'hôpital Trousseau à l'Institut médico
légal un service qui existe depuis
1998 et qui fête donc ses 25 ans
d'existence Pauline Saint-Martin bonjour
vous êtes donc la chef de ce service de
médecine légale est-ce que vous pouvez
d'abord nous présenter les lieux où nous
nous sommes installés alors là on est
dans un bureau de consultation donc aux
unités médicaux judiciaires c'est le
service de consultation de l'institut
médico-légal on reçoit des hommes des
femmes et des enfants toute la journée
qui viennent dans un contexte de
violence pour être examiné et là c'est
un bureau de consultation qu'on a
imaginé avec l'équipe pour plutôt
accueillir des enfants donc il y a des
jeux il y a des crayons de couleurs et
c'est un peu plus doux que les autres
bureaux voilà alors pouvez-vous nous
expliquer les limites de votre travail
en quoi ça consiste quels sont ses
contours je suis médecin légiste donc
c'est une spécialité médicale qui a
plusieurs champs d'activité le plus
connu bien sûr c'est de faire les
autopsies judiciaires à la demande donc
de la justice quand il y a une mort
suspecte voire une mort criminelle mais
ça c'est une toute petite partie de
notre activité c'est 5% de notre
activité l'année dernière on a fait près
de 400 autopsie
la grande partie de notre activité un
autre chance c'est c'est de voir des
victimes de violence qui ont déposé
plainte ou pas et on les examine à la
demande de la justice ou à leur propre
demande on les accompagne dans un
parcours de soins et on voit à peu près
l'année dernière on a vu 4000 victimes
de violence par les médecins légistes
2000 par les psychologues
1400 consultations à la Maison des
Femmes s'arrête jamais ça s'arrête
jamais et encore à tout on est quand
même un petit centre de médecine légale
par rapport à d'autres villes plus
grandes où il y a beaucoup plus de
victimes mais c'est vrai que depuis vous
parliez des 25 ans du service tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que on a vraiment
augmenté de manière très importante
l'activité c'est pas bon signe j'allais
dire alors c'est un signe je sais pas si
c'est bon ou mauvais évidemment ça veut
dire quelque chose de la société mais il
y a plusieurs facteurs c'est pas
simplement ou c'est pas une augmentation
de la violence moi je serais bien en
peine de dire à quoi c'est dû ce qui est
certain c'est que la parole des victimes
est mieux prise en compte et donc et
bien par conséquent on n'en voit plus
ici elles arrivent plus chez nous
d'accord vous êtes également experte
auprès de la Cour d'appel d'Orléans et
vous pouvez être amené à témoigner lors
de procès aux assises est-ce que l'on
peut toujours déterminer les causes de
la mort avec certitude est-ce que par
exemple vous arrivez vous pouvez faire
basculer un procès avec votre témoignage
non je pense qu'il faut être resté très
très humble quand on est médecin légiste
on est vraiment une toute petite part
d'une enquête judiciaire on est un
maillon de la chaîne c'est quand même
assez rare ce qu'on voit dans les la
série télé dans les livres c'est-à-dire
le médecin légiste qui fait l'enquête
alors ça ça n'arrive jamais mais qui
fait basculer un procès c'est pas
vraiment notre rôle nous on apporte un
avis technique dans des affaires
complexes souvent des affaires
criminelles mais pas que être expert
après les tribunaux c'est aussi
analyser des dossiers médicaux voire des
victimes examinées répondre à une
question en particulier sur les
antécédents sur tels lésions c'est un
travail de détails quand on arrive au
procès en général on a la cause du décès
dans ses affaires criminelles donc ce ne
sont pas les causes du décès qui posent
problème ou qui amènent des questions
c'est plutôt le délai de survie le
nombre de lésions y a-t-il des violences
anciennes c'est tout un tas de questions
auxquelles on pense pas immédiatement de
manière plus générale les causes du
décès des gens qui décèdent on ne les a
pas forcément à l'issue d'une autopsie
il faut des examens complémentaires ça
peut prendre du temps et on n'a pas
toutes les réponses aux questions qu'on
se pose
aujourd'hui vous travaillez également au
sein de la Maison des Femmes sur le site
de Bretonneau qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous y faites alors la maison des
femmes c'est effectivement une unité une
partie de l'institut médico-légal il y a
donc l'endroit où on fait les autopsies
il y a l'endroit où on voit des victimes
sur réquisition judiciaire et depuis
juin 2021 il y a une unité qui est à
Bretonneau mais c'est en fait la même
équipe qui accueille des femmes et des
enfants plutôt dans un parcours
préjudiciaire c'est-à-dire qu'on s'est
rendu compte avec le temps que de plus
en plus de victimes notamment de
violences intrafamiliales et bien
voulait chercher de l'aide chercher des
informations des conseils mais ne
souhaitez pas immédiatement déposer
plainte voire même été un peu opposés à
cette solution et donc on a ouvert cette
unité il y en a plusieurs autres qui ont
été ouverts dans d'autres villes pour
aider ces personnes dans leur parcours
donc on voit à la maison des femmes des
femmes qui sont victimes de tout type de
la violence plus de la moitié sont
victimes de violence intrafamiliales
mais qui ne souhaitent pas au début en
tout cas déposer plainte est-ce que
votre métier c'est aussi de les
convaincre de porter plainte ou ça
s'arrête à un constat une écoute ou bien
qu'elle reconnaisse leur statut de
victime alors c'est complexe ça va
dépendre un petit peu de chaque femme et
de chaque situation le métier de médecin
légiste c'est d'être c'est la spécialité
de la violence la médecine légale donc
on a l'habitude de ce phénomène de
violence et des conséquences sur l'état
de santé pour les victimes alors le
terme de convaincre je ne sais pas s'il
est adapté parce qu'effectivement on
sait que le dépôt de plainte peut
amener des solutions et souvent
bénéfique dans le parcours mais suivant
le moment où la femme va venir consulter
à la Maison des Femmes ce n'est pas
forcément
la chose la plus adaptée à proposer à ce
moment-là cependant je suis convaincue
que c'est quand même
un des buts ultime à atteindre pour que
le statut de cette personne en tant que
victime de violence ce soir pris en
compte comment on fait pour ausculter
justement quelqu'un qui vient de subir
des violences j'imagine qu'il faut
prendre des pincettes peut-être faire
preuve de douceur d'empathie la médecine
légale c'est de la médecine donc médecin
légiste c'est médecin quand on est aux
urgences et qu'on accueille quelqu'un
qui s'est fait une entorse de la
cheville il faut aussi l'accueillir avec
empathie avec bienveillance et savoir
conduire à un entretien médical une
victime de violence c'est pareil
évidemment quand on parle de violence
sexuelle quand on parle de maltraitance
pour un enfant il faut savoir à quoi ça
correspond il faut savoir qu'elles vont
être les mécanismes de défense des
personnes on voit des victimes de
violences sexuelles qui ont l'air qui
sont sidérées et qui n'ont pas l'air
très affectés et on sait que ça c'est un
mécanisme de défense donc il faut savoir
ça mais accueillir une victime de
violence c'est faire un travail de
médecin donc effectivement il y a des
particularités on va s'attacher la
vision sur la peau on va bien regarder
chaque centimètre carré de peau on va
faire des prélèvements on a un métier
aussi de constat mais cette prise en
charge elle n'est pas si différente
d'une autre prise en charge médicale
finalement finalement
il n'y a pas forcément d'instituts
médicaux légal dans chaque département
de la région c'est ce que j'ai pu
constater en faisant des recherches pour
préparer cette entretien comment ça se
passe si une victime d'Orléans
veut porter plainte veut que l'on
constate les lésions qu'elle a sur la
peau comment ça marche vous venez elles
doivent venir en fait les instituts
médicaux-légaux ce sont des grands
services qui regroupent à la fois la
pratique des autopsies à la fois
l'accueil des victimes de violence et ça
effectivement au sein de la région il y
en a un seul par contre l'accueil des
victimes au sein d'unités médicaux
judiciaire seule existe dans d'autres
départements de la région il y en a à
Orléans donc les victimes d'Orléans sont
accueillies au CHR d'Orléans et puis
depuis récemment il y en a courge depuis
octobre 2021 et il y en a à Blois depuis
le 1er janvier 2023 avec des médecins
qui travaillent avec nous en
collaboration on est comme un grand
réseau régional où on travaille ensemble
à essayer d'avoir une homogénéisation de
l'accueil des victimes donc dans ces
départements il y a eu des solutions
longtemps il y a eu personne et c'est
vrai que la nuit et le week-end on est
le seul service à faire une astreinte
parfois les victimes se déplacent de
loin mais quand même en journée la
plupart du temps il y a un médecin
légiste pour les accueillir alors on va
maintenant s'intéresser à vous à votre
parcours vous avez été à 31 ans la plus
jeune chef de service de médecine légale
de France est-ce que c'est une fierté
est-ce que ça a été un gros boulot de la
chance comment vous vous avez vécu ça
alors je voudrais pas vous décevoir mais
j'ai lu ça effectivement un jour j'étais
embêté c'était publié et écrit je ne
suis pas sûr que vous êtes même pas sûr
mais j'étais chef de service assez jeune
et c'était une chance avec le recul
quand même je s'était difficile quand
même je trouve que je donne ou pas
forcément c'était difficile parce que
quand on est plus jeune on a moins
d'expérience et et travailler au sein
d'une équipe décider de grandes
organisations de grands chemins
directeur c'est plus facile quand on
prend un peu d'expérience donc là je ne
simplifiez pas les choses mais ça a
toujours été une passion ce métier donc
souvent ça balaye tout et ça permet
d'avancer justement cette passion
comment elle est née comment on
s'intéresse à la médecine légale ça
paraît étrange mais pourquoi pas puisque
est-ce que vous voulez nous expliquer
comment comment vous est venu oui c'est
plus fréquent il y a beaucoup
d'étudiants en médecine qui veulent
faire ça là aussi je vais vous décevoir
parce que en fait je n'ai pas de raison
précise j'ai toujours voulu faire ça
j'ai fait médecine pour être médecin
légiste mais à une époque où c'était
beaucoup moins connu il n'y avait pas de
série télévisée enfin beaucoup moins et
quelques films mais c'était vraiment
ponctuel en fait j'avais l'idée de je
voulais faire un métier qui me semblait
intéressant j'avais une très mauvaise
image du métier que j'allais faire je
pensais que j'allais participer à des
enquêtes judiciaires et participer à la
recherche de la vérité et c'est vrai
c'est ce qui se passe mais c'est pas ça
n'est pas aujourd'hui la plus grande
partie de mon activité comme je vous
l'ai dit c'est d'accueillir des victimes
et d'essayer de les accompagner non je
suis pas déçu mais ce métier s'est
transformé avec le temps heureusement je
pense il est mieux ancré dans la société
mais c'est vrai pour répondre à votre
question à l'époque je pensais que
j'allais participer à des affaires
criminelles et je trouvais ça
passionnant
j'imagine justement que depuis le temps
que vous exercez ce métier il y a des
affaires qui marquent et qu'on oublie
pas forcément est-ce qu'il y en a une
dont vous voudrez bien nous parler alors
ça c'est pas possible en fait en
conservant le secret non non même sans
secret c'est pas possible parce que et
c'est une image que les gens ont de ce
métier si je vous parlais d'une affaire
une affaire qui a fait sensation ça
voudrait dire que la médecine légale
c'est la médecine du fait divers le fait
divers les faits diverses qu'on lit dans
la presse avec des histoires qui n'ont
pas de lien directeurs entre elles c'est
vraiment à l'opposé de ce que je fais en
fait moi mon métier c'est pas un métier
de faits divers c'est un métier de fait
habituel c'est à dire que ce qui me
marque moi c'est le fil rouge entre
toutes les affaires je vois c'est pas la
grande affaire criminelle dont on va
faire l'autopsie et pour laquelle on ira
au procès c'est de voir quotidiennement
ce dont on parlait tout à l'heure
deux ou trois enfants maltraités par
jour des femmes battues des hommes
violés des conflits de voisinage une
affaire criminelle et de voir comme un
fil rouge du quotidien de la violence
finalement entre les gens c'est ça qui
marque donc je réponds de manière
détourner à votre question mais c'est
vraiment sincère ce qui marque au fil du
temps c'est cette espèce de fil rouge
que ce métier représente comme un une
image de la violence dans la société
justement comment comment on fait pour
continuer à avoir la foi avoir foi en la
bonté humaine et j'allais dire
en voyant de la violence au quotidien
est-ce que c'est un métier qui habille
qui vous a abîmé comment on s'en sort ah
on s'en sort mais c'est comme la
médecine il faut pas vraiment sortir la
médecine légale du reste des autres
spécialités médicales la médecine c'est
difficile on voit des maladies des gens
qui souffrent des gens en deuil des
familles et nous on voit des gens
violentés on voit les conséquences sur
leur vie souvent désastreuses
à moyen et à long terme donc oui ça
change la vision qu'on a des choses mais
au même au même titre qu'une autre
spécialité de médecine alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faut il faut en parler avec les
collègues évidemment il y a une notion
de secrets qui fait qu'on peut pas le
sortir du service mais c'est pas plus
mal parce que les gens qui nous
entourent n'ont pas forcément besoin non
plus de recevoir ça mais c'est surtout
qu'il faut avoir d'autres centres
d'intérêt dans la vie c'est tout simple
mais c'est comme tous les métiers
parfois un peu lourds et je pense que
tous mes collègues médecins d'autres
spécialités vous lirez la même chose
en deux mots les qualités nécessaires
selon vous pour exercer ce métier
il faut je pense aimer les gens et il
faut aimer le détail il faut aimer les
gens parce qu'on voit surtout des gens
vivants qui souffrent et qui ont besoin
voilà qu'on leur parle et qu'on les
écoute mais il faut aussi aimer le
détail écoutez merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions c'est la
fin de cette invité de la rédaction
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite un nouveau programme sur TV tour
Val de Loire
[Musique]